Our subject today
is Simon McNeil.
He's a self-professed medium.
He's almost here.
For those of you
that don't know,
I've recently lost my son Miles.
People like Simon
like to prey on grief.
Ready whenever you are.
I need complete darkness.
Or rather they do.
All the dead have stories.
There is a place where these
horrors are transcribed.
I'm not sure where
I'm going, but it
felt like I was being followed.
We're headed to Ravermoore.
Is it a nice place?
No.
Here.
The dead.
They are so much closer
than you realize.
I wasn't planning on stopping.
I just think I'm really tired.
Come.
You're safe here.
I just have a thing with noises.
It's neurological.
Would've probably
been better if I just
didn't stop taking the meds.
[GASPING]
Oh.
I'm so sorry, dear.
I didn't mean to startle you.
Man, some bad shit
happened here.
Urban decay, that's
what happened.
We like to think everyone
who stays here is family.
We all die.
But sometimes the
stories of our passing
must be forever carved
into our collective memory.
But all stories end here.